the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or to view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
okay so let's move into our topic for
the day so we've got a couple things
we're going to talk a little bit about
in a silent way and then I want to have
us have a chance to present what you
have created and we'll see how this goes
so this is pretty much at least in this
second part unknown we don't know what's
going to happen so it should be
interesting but in terms of a Silent Way
did everybody get to listen to that and
what do you what do you make of that
composition call the Silent Way in a
silent way by Miles Davis what do you
make of that what did you hear happening
same modal so I didn't have like a
definite chord changes which i think
here so if I go like Spacey okay good
modal Spacey ambiguous anybody else so
okay the instrumentation was just very
different from the other Miles Davis
pieces we've listened to
this tile and everything like it being
so like this slowly back almost freeform
piece with a bullet i guess like
electronic feels mm-hmm right and
because what were some over some of the
accompanying instruments and they
sounded like maybe like i'll send fender
rhodes actually to fender rhodes piano
which is sort of old-school but you see
these around a lot of fact we have one
at MIT which current pns with the f je
likes to call it out and play it so
that's great and and somebody playing
playing the organ as well as that what
else what else did you hear instruments
the how prominent the instruments were
to one another was more uniform and like
recordings we visit to meaning like it's
not like that obviously the trumpet had
melody
right right so a lot more diversity of
who is sort of in the lead and that kind
of thing was it only that sort of
ambiguous free-floating sound that only
that or did it do something else
okay a regular beat and what was the
what was the rhythmic feel there but I
mean was it jazz was it
percussive okay anybody else have a term
that could characterize the what it went
into we all heard the piece right and it
was a fairly long piece right like about
20 minute piece okay I was sure you
would catch this it goes into
essentially a rock kind of a feel it's a
more subtle rockfield than what you
would have heard from a rock band in
that period but it's nonetheless that's
what it's going to became this became
sort of the signature piece that moved
jazz into what was called jazz rock or
fusion in 1969's when this came out so
and in fact this middle part is the
longest part of the whole piece it's
it's where most of the soloing happens
and then it returns to the sort of quiet
quieter more lyrical thing at the end
and I put these names on the board
because it turns out that this is
actually a piece that was put together
in the studio it's a studio realization
you could say and the first part is
called in a silent way and that's
composed by joe zawinul who is one of
the three keyboard players that shows up
at the beginning and at the end in the
middle is a piece that both zawinul and
Miles Davis co compose called it's about
that time which is the more funky rock
type of piece and so they decided to
essentially blend these pieces and the
further thing about this is this was an
early attempt by people in the studio
one guy particular tale nicera who
worked with Miles Davis a lot to
essentially sort of you could say cut
and paste because they used to have to
splice tape to make cuts and paste them
back together before a digital editing
and so there's some of that that's going
on in the middle section and in fact the
last section is exactly what was played
for the first four minutes it's just a
replica it's a replication it's the same
exact music just paste it in at the end
so it sort of calls into a new
perspective what is
improvisation and what is jazz
composition really and you're going to
have a chance to talk with Neil Leonard
when he comes in about another month
about exactly that electronic usage
computer usage and improvisation stuff
but this is sort of an early attempt the
other thing that I wanted us to listen
to this for is that this basically is a
jazz version of the format that we're
going to here on Sunday at the Indian
concert because how many people have had
the music of India course anybody have
that course you've had that anybody else
and so you know that the way that the
music in raga tradition works is there's
a very slow presentation as it's called
of the raga the main melody and then
after that is allowed to be stated in a
very lyrical free-floating way then you
get this rhythmic sense with a
particular cycle or at ala that comes in
and so it's hard to believe that Miles
Davis was not influenced by John
Coltrane who had previously been part of
miles as band but Coltrane as many of
you know had explored the music of India
and so it's sort of like an cross
influence coming back from what somebody
had originally been a player in miles
band coming back to inform him and this
piece really has a very Indian at least
pattern to it if not Indian music it's
not a raga but it is its own particular
mode as people have said anybody know
what mode it was or did you try to
figure that out
was it did if you get in during because
it began with
flat 7
okay anybody have a different take on it
figure out which notes we're in the mode
I could put remember them I was playing
a long ago but didn't think about what
the actual of the actual note ok so to
worry but you tried to play along with
this I feel like I figured out which
NESTA's ok anybody remember what was
going on at the same time that the
melody was being played
so obviously I'm going to suggest you go
listen to it again so we can hear more
deeply inside of what's going on let me
just come over the piano for a second I
made a brief transcription of this
melody and what's going on is if I can
just get over there we've got the first
thing that we have with this is a drone
a drone is just a long note underneath
the melody and we've done that with some
of our exercises right where we've just
had a basic tonal center it's the act
like I didn't call it that but that's
what it is same thing in Indian music
there's a drone established by one of
the instruments and then the melody
works off that so in this case it's an e
so you're always hearing this e and then
it's actually this is the melody
it starts on the third if you were at E
and you had a major chord it's actually
the third of the E major chord but you
never get that cord you just get this
and that's a big interval that's a minor
seventh jump and here's where you get
the tip off of what the mode is and what
that is is e 2d natural which means that
it's e essentially mixolydian because if
you had come on that same phrase and
gone it's totally different
and it winds up on the fifth which is
the B which is again an open sound so
except for occasionally getting a major
third of what might have been the cord
it's really ambiguous which a number of
you said yeah Jamie at a point yeah it's
funny because the part of the piece that
I wrote which I wrote after I was this
song is an e mixolydian so obviously he
plans on this bike this piece and that's
going to as soon as you play that yes
that's okay that's that's how we learned
that's how we and that's a great homage
to this particular piece so what we've
got here in other words is a pretty
simple mode it's it's just one and it
almost sounds like its major except for
that little trick note that i pointed
out but that's a very distinctive note
and that so when you listen to this
again pay attention to that because it
really is the thing that sets this piece
off apart from many others now the
interesting thing about this is
according to people who have really
studied this and interviewed people who
are on the recording session when this
was joe zawinul who wrote this this to
the one we just talked about when he
brought this into the recording session
he had chords with it he had chord
changes written for it and Miles Davis
saw this and said why don't you just
said to the guitar player John
McLaughlin why don't you just play the
melody and it sort of took McLaughlin to
back it was like well what am I going to
do with the cords in the piano player so
what are we going to do with the chords
said don't play him just Dave Holland
was developed gesundheit the bass player
just put a bee pedal underneath all of
this play the melody and let that be the
whole thing and so according to these
people again at the session they did
this and no one was sure how was going
to turn out and when they heard the
playback they were just astonished
because it made so much sense and this
is sort of the next level after kind of
blue in fact it was ten years after kind
of blue so it's sort of like moving from
that building on that direction
incorporating some Indian ish type
things
that and coming out with what we had so
I really do recommend you listen to this
again try to hear some of these other
things that are happening and when you
hear the the middle section this other
tune that's called it's about that time
pay attention this because this now
shifts the tonal center up a half step
to F some people say is mixolydian I
hear it as a pentatonic sound so see if
you can maybe play along with that that
would be a good one to play around and
just see what you can figure out on the
baseline and that's all it is is a
baseline with a lot of textures remember
we've talked about textures from the
other instruments and this is
particularly so with the three keyboard
so it's a great piece and it bears
listening to again ok so the assignment
for you guys was to come up with a piece
that was similarly a long flowing melody
of between 10 and 15 notes and then
figure out a way to present it so who
would would like to present their piece
so this is the senility so it goes like
this that's just sort of the thing that
we're going to play around on is this
and there's a second part that that will
come in occasionally
just like that all right so won't you
I
Oh
Oh
every night well your play those opening
knows that you play when you told us
what it was made out of
be just like that the little melody
knows who you would play a role Sarah
what is it so like what kind of music
does that sound like it sounds like
Indian music have you heard much Indian
music oh yeah before that's what I must
be going into your consciousness yeah at
one point I was like other sounds Linden
so when you hear the concert on Sunday
what you're going to hear is something
very similar to that the slope Ruiz
that'll be the presentation of the raga
that sort of idea that you just did and
in fact when you got into that rhythmic
thing particularly you're picking style
as well as piano that would be very
similar to what the tabla the drummer
would be doing to give a percussive
thing so this is great this is like
unconscious processing of where we're
going so brilliant and very nice playing
on the other side so folk very nice and
bring in bringing out you're bringing
out the what would be called the
characteristic feature of the mode or if
it was a rag that Rob there's certain
particular things and Phil scarf when he
comes a week from well beyond next
Monday he'll be talking about that very
particular specific thing so very well
done good job good job we would like to
go next goes from P Dorian G mixolydian
C major so yeah piano should be playing
clothes and then the melody I was
thinking flute and oboe could maybe
improvise unplugging it like when you
get to the major
that's C major okay sorry yeah there's
not really time to this so i should have
suggested which notes might be shorter
which ones might be longer but take
whatever the time you want that's why I
figured maybe it's not best have lots of
people playing at once I'm Jason to have
it sort of move around um time to just
yeah I think once would not be enough so
maybe what slots do two or three times
common i'm going to set this appt
because transposing and keep it quiet
you
I
very nice so who was you were playing
the actual melody and you were
improvising with the mode or something
or around it sure oh yeah percussive
improvisation at the very beginning oh
yeah sorry testicle notes very very nice
very nice cool yeah I've got a simple
melody which had like again to be paid
by the flute just sort of loop it around
I didn't explicitly say what nodes were
longer than a little treat but in the
middle there I've got these three notes
which I kind of want to everyone to get
in on specifically was no specific like
those exact notes oh yeah specific isn't
it so everyone play like in unison or as
you get for a long yeah so we should all
be playing but you have to know that we
all play the whole time but those three
notes be played with nothing you
everyone's playing you a whole time okay
maybe the start actually the first time
through just the piano and then when we
meet for her and for you guys to see
Frisian stick with the e the most the
time but also at least at the start
bringing like the a and the B
specifically and it's it's not too slow
so just
it's just all the whiteness yeah
very nice and so what was visits one
mode or 22 miles this one was very nice
very nice and and was your part
prescribed or were you improvising so
there was three notes sort of in the
middle of that doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo-doo-doo I guess I'm not
quitting any key but yeah so there was
three notes was every time it was
prescribed other than that improvising
okay good and the same for you other
folk very nice very nice but you were
playing the melon berry nice good good
good
you
you
you
you
very nice so you ate you actually had
cords right now chord symbol which is an
interesting way to go so this we haven't
had that yet today I don't think we
might we did you have cords in you so
that's what that because I was going to
write that on top of it i want to
mention some of that so that's an
interesting way to think about and we
can explore this a little more I don't
want to take time now but it's an
interesting way to think about it's
another another facet just try this take
those first five notes and play them a
little more like a rhythmical idea but
like this bop boo boo bee bo bop and
then the next one and next and then the
next five same way bop ba doo bee doo
the next pop Bobby doubt yeah just just
do that do that over and over again and
Alex play those same chords but in time
now so i'm going to count this off one
two one two three four
okay i'm just showing that because this
would be another way to make a variation
of what you've done in other words
similar to silent way you've got your
lyrical thing up front and then you
could turn it into a rhythmical gesture
let's say and if you had yet a third
instrument you guys could be essentially
the rhythm section and somebody else
oboe whatever flute could take a solo on
top of that just another thing to think
about in terms of extension very nice
very nice
did you have a written part no you were
just making something else you're
improvising and you was you were playing
this it was this but so you can watch
exactly so you had a rhythmical scheme
but you didn't put a meter with it so it
wasn't like four for six hours very nice
very nice I mastering you keep going
until one of you dropped mainly you
because you have to keep breanna that
was really nice that was really nice we
could have gotten everybody involved I
would have taken up about an hour it
would be great so the summer remember if
you have if you get hired for a job
sometime and you run out of material you
can always do something like this fill
up easily five minutes 30 minutes and
you're in your golden so if you run out
of your set let's just a practical tip
very nice so if you want to put your
name on that let me have that so I guess
you guys have to run while they're
leaving in the next person decides who
wants to be I just want to say thing
about chords and I know this Jacob this
is your piece so I don't want to say
anything but you had said D Dorian you
also so put D minor D minor chord to
indicate you wanted an E minor chord and
that's fine that's perfectly fine
sometimes and you see this on the the
lead sheet for so what
which we which we looked at and we've
studied it'll say D Dorian D minor
seventh it's a shorthand for saying
that's a cord that works with the D
Dorian scale but in fact it's often not
so good to use this it's much better
just to put the mode because if you do
that then the piano player is
immediately going to think let me play
that for note chord which is triads and
triads remember is not the sound that we
typically want with motor we want a
quarrel like a fourth a fourth base
thing so when people do this when they
put that down there sometimes it just
you're sort of snapped into that other
way of thinking it's not that it's wrong
it's just that it's not quite into the
motive into the mode into the idiom of
what we're trying to do with modal stuff
so okay thank you all so who would like
to go next
change that especially after that
conclusion electric guitar guitar out
just like I've decided if you like and
then basically transition to be yourself
after one
news report
you
you
you
so that again that was like what a
single melody and that's all just some
verbal instructions very good very very
nice very nice and please okay let's
keep moving along and I want to urge us
if we could make the presentation just a
little bit shorter just to make sure
everybody gets a chance to have their
thing I heard so who would like to go
next okay yeah so it's dorian and it's
just a basic melody so what I want was
like the flute just like start the
melody and just keep looping back
through it and has a rhythm and then I
want of the piano to just I guess add
their own improvisation to it
you
very nice piano what were you doing
reading off what that was what were you
reading off that melody yes or I was
trying to sort of align the rhythms
playing mostly though so you were making
that up the fourth idea but you were
following that yeah I didn't play any of
the melody Idris good good who did that
sound like to you or to anybody else
what did that sound like the piano and
flute the other a little bit a little
bit anybody else at classical any other
classical it's not very much like Ravel
to me and I in the kind of blue
situation if I don't know if you read
the pages that were up there I don't
know if this was in those pages that I
put on stellar it talked about how both
bill evans and Miles Davis adored Ravel
and that in fact when they would listen
to music in their own apartments that's
who they often would listen to
interesting for a jazz person and that
that was very definitely in Bill Evans
mind so your chant you're channeling
this so this is great it's beautiful a
beautiful flute flute playing very very
nice idea really nice ideas wonderful
done I'm getting a kick out of the fact
that most you guys are not playing in
your own piece that's very intense
because you want to hear what's going on
I understand that
and kind of set up a cycle of some sort
and then I'd like to improvise over his
melody but starting with notes that's
okay i I don't I hope it works i'm not
exactly sure yet and then i would like
you to play I guess whatever cycle he
says other people just like play chords
under it but I guess I like half
you
again you didn't sing us that's very
interesting i was sure you were going to
that was very nice and actually as it's
interesting how these are just emerging
just by the way its people are
volunteering but this this this sort of
could be a perfect complement to what
your piece was I mean it would make
sense to me k now you come out okay so
I'm not song and some of the rhythmical
people you were clearly kind of tool
with so sex is going to fit military and
the rest of us will just play like soft
courts and D Dorian I wrote out a pretty
specific rhythm but you can take this is
just the transposition of that
that's it so it should be
Oh
you
very nice very nice to feel one of the
realm of french impressionistic musica
this is lovely it's very peaceful very
did that work like you thought it would
except for the transpose it very much
yeah just in a different key yeah it was
one note that was I don't know that's
right yeah so I just know what happened
to the ride but yeah so where I was
doing the Dorian on the sax that should
have been a g-sharp massages okay made
that change but yeah it did sound kind
of weird son oh yeah the general mood
was basically yes going for very nice
very nice okay who wants to go next I of
our remaining contestants
you
you
so if i got from here and strike sort of
like inter intertwining or interlocking
segments is that the idea yeah it was
kind of again the trigger I think I need
to like fix marriage oh oh but that's
not it really nice and the exotic rating
was cool yeah really good very well done
you
you
you
cool cool um so I don't have anything
written I'm just going I guess from more
of an open conception but I was thinking
just me yet so obviously candy Doreen
okay so the only real like solid concept
i have like something of a melody so i
guess i was thinking i would just kind
of riff off of that and i wanted you to
have kind of like a minor sound oh yes
so I don't know I guess kind of do what
you want what they want like your meat
or just sort of chords God yeah I mean I
guess more chords okay yeah right cool
so yeah I guess you can started off
whoo
Oh
you
you
very nice very nice and I was waiting
for someone to do this not have anything
written down yeah I guess I'm meeting
next week but no no I but but I was
waiting for that because that's often
how our improvisational conceptions
generate I mean I asked you to come up
with something but I don't think I said
write it down I said come up with
something and writing it down is
perfectly fine and yours was almost all
hand written with a couple notes other
people had just just the notes other
people had some notes and chords any of
these are fine but they just give us a
generative point from which to work so
very cool and obviously what happened in
each of these instances was way more
than what you had on paper that's the
idea in other words what these are
wonderful and if you didn't give me one
of these and you and you had it as a
written out for my need to see that but
the point is what happened in the room
is the music that's the music this these
are all starting points these are all
springboard so you're all doing
wonderfully so give yourself a round of
applause really really nice so that's it